[Music]
hey wisecrack jared here today we're
breaking down everyone's favorite
insomniac his soap salesman BFF and
they're super super secret underground
club for dudes who like to beat each
other senseless that's right we're
talking about that thing you're not
supposed to talk about foremost Fight
Club is about chiseled men who like to
knock each other's teeth out and destroy
private property to escape the monotony
of consumer culture but there's
something about Fight Club we often
overlook is Tyler Durden really the
suave Savior we thought he was welcome
to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of Fight Club and as always
spoilers ahead Fight Club begins with
our nameless protagonist slash narrator
as he tries to beat insomnia and
complete his life one IKEA shelf at a
time his doctor suggests he see real
pain at a testicular cancer support
group and our narrator finally finds the
key to sleep crying his eyes out but
another faker Marla singer ruins it
flaunting her lack of balls to are now
again sleepless narrator all that gets
put on hold when the narrator's
apartment blows up destroying his
perfectly manicured lifestyle and
forcing him to live with one Tyler
Durden he and Tyler share some drinks go
on wild and zany adventures and convince
lots of people to be pass out of each
other also domestic terrorism but we'll
get to that the most overt theme in
Fight Club is the drudgery of consumer
capitalism our narrator lives a tiny
life of tedium working a job he hates
throughout the film he looks half asleep
staring absent-mindedly into space
unable to feel anything at one point the
narrator tells us when you have insomnia
you're never really asleep and you never
really awake as he watches an
infomercial suggesting that he's not
only half conscious because of insomnia
but also consumerism but more
importantly Fight Club shows a world of
what sociologists call rationalization
rationalization in this sense isn't
quite using rationality in the way you
might think but using a certain kind of
rationality to organize society
essentially rationalization favors
efficiency over tradition custom or
individual desires so
for example instead of getting your pies
made with love from the nice little
beggar down the street you get them from
a factory where they're made on a cold
dead assembly line modern social life is
pretty much dominated by rationalization
it's organized to accommodate large
numbers of people in the most efficient
way possible everything in the
narrator's life is designed for a
specific purpose mass-produced and
unrelentingly predictable down to his
bosses tie it must have been Tuesday he
was wearing his cornflower blue tie even
calls his own home a condo on the 15th
floor of a filing cabinet for widows and
young professionals describing his
existence as nothing more than an
efficient way to store and organize
things Fight Club shows us that
efficiency has its downsides especially
in a world where efficient means
efficiently consuming to the point where
as Tyler Durden says things you own end
up owning me the narrator describes
everything as being a copy of a copy of
a copy consumer products and consumers
are indistinguishable from each other
the drive this point home director David
Fincher even put a Starbucks cup in
almost every scene of the film for
philosophers Theodor Adorno and Max
Horkheimer this trend of
indistinguishable commodities is a
direct result of rationalization
according to them everything were sold
comes from a standardized menu of
constructs all designed to be as
cost-effective as possible while
promoting fake differences consider the
Dubey which may or may not be different
than a comforter I don't know I tried to
read about it gave up know what a duvet
is
Humphry like just a blanket guys like
you and I know what it today is is this
essential to our survival and the
hunter-gatherer sense of the word no
what are we consumers right some good
marketing might make the things we buy
seem different from each other but in
reality they're all pretty much the same
copies of copies of copies this
commodification of all things makes life
pretty dull and also kind of fascist for
Adorno and Horkheimer and for the
characters in Fight Club living in a
rationalized world can have a
dehumanizing effect turning everyone
into lonely alienated drones at the
behest of consumer capitalism living
life just following orders if you will
flown around the country on business
trips the narrator describes the
isolation that comes with a
single-serving lifestyle everything is
small and disposable even the people he
meets the people I meet on each flight
their single-serving friends between
takeoff and landing we have our time
together that's all we get after getting
in a car accident he muses about the
dehumanizing effect of his own work I
never been in a car accident
this must have been what all those
people felt like before I filed them as
statistics in my reports so how do we
cope with a single-serving lifestyle one
might be tempted to say get a hobby bro
but for Adorno and Horkheimer amusement
under modern-day capitalism has just
become a prolongation of work hobbies
and entertainments serve to rejuvenate
us so we can go back to work the next
day but those same things that keep us
sane and our off hours are still
determined by the system
this makes amusement the after images of
the work process itself in other words
if we are working we're buying
mass-produced stuff to help us feel
better about the fact that we have to go
to work again the next day I'd flip
through catalogs and wonder what kind of
dining set defines me as a person or we
get the fat sucked out of us which was
caused by our own decadent lifestyle we
were selling rich women their own fat
asses back to them the narrator's way of
coping is still just an extension of
living as a consumer in a rationalized
world very respectable Dorner went as
far as directly comparing this kind of
mass consumption to fascism for him the
mechanism of rationalization that causes
people to blindly throw their money at
big companies like Starbucks is the same
mechanism that causes people to throw
themselves at fascist ideology much like
the citizens of a fascist state mobilize
under a totalitarian dictator modern
society has mobilized under capitalism
it isn't until his apartment
mysteriously blows up that the narrator
finds a new way to resist
rationalization after losing all his
precious IKEA furniture he trades in a
leading capitalism for a place in Tyler
Durden zkk rumbling mansion on paper
street paper street is the exact
opposite of his former apartment while
the other one was small efficient and
well decorated paper Street is
needlessly large disorganized and dirty
if his apartment was rational paper
Street is irrational in his new home he
joins Tyler Durden in his fight against
consumer culture Tyler the charming
charismatic leader of Fight Club
champions are resistance against
oppressive consumerism offering the
narrator an escape and a way to reclaim
his identity but what does escaping
rationalization have to do with punching
people in the face
Howler's resistance takes things a bit
further than your run-of-the-mill
critique of capitalism he frames
consumerism as an assault on masculinity
the men in Fight Club basically fear
that society is turning them into women
they feel degraded by their jobs the
narrator in this sense is the perfect
image of an emasculated consumer he's
weak and goes to support groups where he
hugs people and cries you know girl
stuff at the testicular cancer support
group some of them have literally become
emasculated one of the participants
laments he's been cuckolded as his wife
has had the child they could never have
had with a new man
she had a first shot last week on a girl
the film really drives this symbolism
home with the character of Bob once a
bodybuilder Bob literally loses his
balls to testicular cancer and grows
[ __ ] tits as a result of hormone
therapy yes we're men men is what we are
his loss of masculinity results in
estrangement from his family and he
feels completely dehumanized now I'm
divorced my two grown kids return my
phone calls the narrator and Tyler also
discussed their absentee fathers
wondering what the role of being raised
by women has played in their lives or a
generation of men raised by women and
Tyler tells the narrator man it could be
worse women cut off your penis where you
sleeping toss it out the window a moving
car seriously this whole movie is about
losing your balls and/or dick given the
emasculation of modern consumer society
Fight Club is appealing because it
allows members to express themselves by
acting in a way they can't in everyday
life being really really violent which
is something they associate with being
men with a capital F masculinity through
aggression provides a way for the men to
cope with their girly day jobs and
domestic consumer behavior but while
Tyler Durden laments the fake kind of
masculinity sold to us by Hollywood he
sells them another kind of manliness the
second half of Fight Club is all about
how Tyler Durden has taken all the
things Project Mayhem is supposed to
rebel against repackaged it and so
fold it to his Project Mayhem Stooges
the members of Fight Club just become
copies of copies of each other they
shaved their heads called each other
magnet they even lose their names in
Project Mayhem we have no names
rebelling against a system that's made
them faceless drones they become well
faceless drones and remember all that
stuff about losing your balls while
testicles under the reign of Tyler
aren't faring much better either the
movie gives us an early glimpse of
what's to come as Tyler Durden just
repeatedly punches this guy in the dick
Project Mayhem later threatens to cuts
everyone's balls off publicly state that
there is no Underground or these guys
gonna take the balls even its own
founder / Bob and the narrator Fight
Club has simply replaced the support
groups in their lives and they chat
about their Fight Club days like one
might talk about their weekly support
group schedules Tuesdays and Thursdays
Tyler acts like a strong father figure
for the narrator and the rest of Project
Mayhem I will carry you kicking and
screaming in the end but like the
narrator's father he left when I was
like 6 years old
Tyler abandons him the most devoted
members of Fight Club are put through
intense hazing to become members of
Project Mayhem before they can join
prospective members have to stand
outside the paper Street mansion for
three days without food or shelter and
are verbally and physically abused those
who tough it out are allowed inside the
house and become part of a well-oiled
machine that blows up computer stores
terrorizes politicians and sends
corporate sculptures rolling into coffee
shops as Tyler's movement gains momentum
it transforms from an after-school
activity
into a fascist cult that might just be
as bad as the capitalism they rebelled
against in the first place
built himself an army we are all part of
Project Mayhem
operates through strict rules and
systematic efficiency they even rely on
capital to run properly and fund their
activities by making and selling soap
out of human fat stolen from a
liposuction clinic the difference is
that now instead of reporting to the
demands of their corporate bosses
members report to their patriarchal
authoritarian leader Tyler Durden sooner
or later we all became what Tyler wanted
us to be chapters begin springing up all
over the United States
the narrator even calls them franchises
Tyler had been busy setting up
franchises all over the country the
entire time Project Mayhem has been
plotting toward a master plan blowing up
the offices of the credit card companies
the narrator discovers this plan and
also discovers that he and Tyler Durden
are the same person
relationship Tyler we have just lost
cabin pressure Tyler Durden was the
manly virile complement to the
narrator's emasculated helplessness and
if we recall when the narrator says
early on that and suddenly I realized
that all of this the gun the bombs the
revolution has got something to do with
a girl named Marla singer he probably
means that his spiral into psychosis
began when he needed to create an
alter-ego to be with her they were
looking for a way to change her life I
could not do this on your own
all the ways in which you could be
that's me
it looked like you want to look like you
want to guy him smart capable and most
importantly I'm free and all the ways in
you or not he's able to get rid of
Durden by shooting himself in the face
but the damage is already done
the building's collapse supposedly to
reset society's debt although I'm not
sure how that actually works just like
Tyler and the narrator are two sides of
the same person for Adorno and
Horkheimer fascism and capitalism are
two sides of the same coin they argued
that both fascism and capitalism see
human beings as numbers instead of
individuals alienated objects to be used
and controlled so what do you guys think
what's worse succumbing to the allure of
Ikea catalogs and coffee chains or
following the orders of a fascist soap
salesman offering promises of humanity
let us know what you think in the
comments or don't but if you want to
hear more about what we think about
movies check out our new movie podcast
called show me the meaning in it we're
breaking down some of the best and worst
movies ever made but we've got a bunch
more plan for you guys and we want to
hear what you want to hear so send us
suggestions on which movies to break
down next at movies at wisecrack Co
click here or at the link in the
description to subscribe to show me the
meaning on Apple podcast Google Play
stitcher or wherever else you get your
podcast thanks again guys catch y'all
next time peace
[Music]